hello i'm alana and i work in the games
industry
uh today some news was dropped about
uh let me just pull the article over for
you shall i wb games nemesis system
patent was approved this week after
multiple attempts
uh warner brothers interactive
entertainment publishers of middle east
shadow of mordor and its
2017 sequel shadow of war both developed
by monoloth entertainment
have finally managed to secure a pattern
for the franchise's signature
nemesis system i remember when this came
out um i worked at ign at the time
and the nemesis system is so cool the
way that it works is so so so cool
uh i wouldn't even really know how to
describe it to anyone who doesn't know
let me see if there's like a
tidy description of it somewhere it's
basically a system
that allows certain enemies to kind of
evolve in a ranks in a hierarchy and
remember you and
and have their ranks escalated if you
fight them and lose um
is incredibly cool and when it came out
i remember having all of these
conversations that were like
man why haven't more games done this i i
feel like every game is going to want to
do this because it's
just a really unique way to give a lot
of
vague enemy npcs uh a lot more depth
make them more menacing make fights have
a bit more meaning
a really unique take on that combat
system in a game
where a lot of things weren't quite that
unique if i'm being totally honest
and i wanted to talk about this because
i feel like a lot of the reaction that
i'm seeing from
you know the general public your average
gamer um doesn't understand
why this system being patented or any
system like it being patented
is kind of awful and could present some
really big problems but
i'll continue with the article before we
we get to that the u.s patent and
trademark office released an issue
notice on february 3rd 2021 stating that
the patent would go into effect on
february 23rd of this year
warner bros has the option to maintain
the patent through 2035 providing they
keep up with the necessary fees
patent filed as nemesis system
characters nemesis sports social
vendettas and followers in computer
games
effectively codifies the functions of
monolith's nemesis system and
the sum of its parts as the property of
wb
it does go on to say that the language
in the application is fairly obtuse um
but patterns generally always are
and the short version is that it covers
a system featuring procedurally
generated npcs that exist in a hierarchy
and interact with and will remember the
actions of players which again
such a cool thing about it um have their
appearance behavior altered by players
and whose place in that hierarchy can
change and affect the position of other
npcs in said hierarchy
um that's you know i guess that's how
they describe it and why it was
difficult for me to describe
with uh some images here kind of
explaining how it works
so then i guess i should show you some
of the comments i'm talking about just
to illustrate that
because i'm not a fan of people on the
internet are saying
without giving you actual examples of
what people on the internet are saying
let me find it so here are some examples
of what i'm talking about here
um dexter here said i get being upset
but you can't hate on a company for
coming up with an ingenious idea then
capitalizing on it by putting a patent
on it it would be stupid not to patent
a genius idea for future use it's their
creation
i don't see the issue here those games
are a lot of fun they are not talked
about enough i do agree
with that part i do think the nemesis
system is absolutely fantastic why
people moaning they designed it and then
went through the effort
of putting it into a game that belongs
to them so they have the right to
protect it now i do
want to say that i was going to cover
this person's tweet but they seem to
have already you know spoken about it
definitely part of the issue with wb
specifically doing this is that it seems
really hypocritical
um because so many of the systems that
already exist in shadow of mordor
are from other games they are blatantly
similar to assassin's creed for example
but the issue is a lot broader than that
and it's an issue with patenting
technology in general on one hand it is
entirely possible that doing this means
that wb will lease it to other studios
that is
possible but seems very unlikely to me
does mean if they have that proper
ownership
um i'm sure that system was incredibly
difficult to build that they could
let other people use it if they pay for
it which means it could be easier to get
it into other games
i don't think that's likely to be what
uh the purpose of this whole thing is
though
in reality this is a major issue and
something that
i definitely do not support um you know
even if i agree this is something that
they made that's really really cool
um i still feel like the dev team is
probably not
in support of this either even the ones
who spent a really long time figuring
this out and
actually coding it i would be very
surprised if many people
outside of the business side of this
actually agree with this choice
the truth is and a lot of game designers
will say this um
i have you know game directors who are
close friends like
like mike bithell who has said this on
this channel but it's also just
something that
i feel like is is fairly unanimous
across the games industry
every game has copied another game
that is the truth of it every game that
you play is
iterative of another game uh in a way
that's very blatant and in a way that
allows us to improve on systems that
have already existed and make a lot of
really cool stuff for a really clear
example
the developers of neo-automata uh
platinum games
when they said that they were figuring
out what size the map should be
they basically just decided to make it
the exact same size as ocarina of time
that's how they figured out the map size
but obviously it gets a lot more
elaborate than that but these things
are things that game devs have not been
shy about historically and it's not
copying um because you can't really copy
code that you haven't seen
you can take a system from someone else
that you really like the look of and put
it into your game obviously
you would still have to build that
system yourself which is why things are
different
it's how they improve it's how they're
iterated on it's how games
the entire industry as a whole is moving
forward and figuring out cool ideas
because people are taking this medium
that is uh tremendously difficult to
even conceptualize
and is becoming extremely collaborative
by virtue of everyone
kind of copying off of everyone else
this isn't something that should be seen
as a slight it's it's something that
that helps games
going forward and putting a patent on a
system like the nemesis system
really just means that something that
was very cool that could
shape video games that could have
systems that players really really enjoy
that could
you know change and be refined by other
studios for a really long time
is now limited dramatically which limits
every single studio who was working on a
game where they might have wanted to do
something creative like that with their
hostile npcs
it is a massive limitation to creative
arts in general to do this kind of thing
for every pattern like this that passes
every other game has to think okay well
we can't put this idea that we really
like in
even if it's you know not a one-to-one
from that game because we can't steal
their code
legally obviously because this this past
wb are legally allowed to do it they are
if within their rights to do it i'm
definitely not arguing that it passed
they are legally allowed to do it
confirmed and that that spans off into
another part of this that can become
really difficult
is it is somebody's job to make sure
that a game is not
uh violating a patent that can cost
thousands of dollars that can limit
studios
really significantly because you have to
make sure that you are not toeing on the
line of any other pattern people can be
employed
just to look out for patent issues i've
also personally
known people who've worked on the patent
side where they go through
tons of materials trying to find
violations to make the patent holder
money
it can get really really nasty cost
people a lot of money
and limit things even if it's just
because people are frustrated by the
existence of these patents
one major issue with this is that it's
pretty broad phrasing it is limiting for
a lot of reasons and potentially is
stopping people
from being able to create really cool
antagonist
systems because they made it so broad i
think it's also frustrating
because wb aren't even using the system
in other games
like it just stopped there it just
stopped with shadow of war maybe if they
were putting it into other games like i
really hoped that they'd put it in mad
max that would have been cool as hell
but they didn't
then i would maybe think okay well
they've used this a whole bunch of times
maybe it's a little bit less exciting
assassin's creed does have a slightly
similar system
there are other games that have toyed
with this idea but creativity in a lot
of cases
in a medium like this where we're still
even figuring out what the limits of it
are
often comes from seeing another idea and
making it a lot cooler
and then every single game after that
gets cooler as a result
but if it's just straight up nope you
cannot use this thing
despite the fact that our game's really
similar to assassin's creed you cannot
use this thing that is
very broadly described i mean the
wording of social vendettas isn't it
ultimately
while i i do agree they're within their
rights to do it legally they are allowed
to do it
it is limiting to video games as a whole
every game that comes after this
is limited by this patent existing it
costs developers money it limits
creativity and it limits iteration
and our industry is one that is born of
iteration and to suggest that it isn't
is just naive
game developers are inspired by other
video games that is a reality they are
inspired by other mediums
and limiting that inspiration or telling
us that we can't use a system
like this with the broad phrasing of
social vendettas
means that any idea that you might have
had that could loop into this system is
just cut from day one
even if that idea could have grown way
beyond that and become a very different
thing from the jump
if it seems like it's going to violate
that patent it doesn't get created
so yeah i hope this does even a slightly
good job of explaining it to people who
maybe don't understand
kind of the breadth of why this really
sucks i'm also just always worried about
the precedent of the more stuff that
gets
slapped with this kind of ban hammer
effectively
the more limiting video games will
become in the long run i mean this is
until 2035.
i just hope that you know since it's
happened and isn't too likely to be
reformed
that wb use it more at the very least
since
nobody else can use anything even like
it
with that vague terminology such a cool
system it sucks to have it even like
soured by this you know i will see you
guys next time bye